بريطانيا تترك حصانها الخاسر
والسبب روسيا وكيسنجر يبشر
الامر بينما قديروف يسخر. اهلا
بكم في قائمة العقوبات الغربية.
باخموت على كفي عفريت يا سادة.
فما الذي يجري? الانجليز يستعدون
وبوتين لقد بدأ التغيير العالمي
الصين واليابان في منافسة غير
عادلة وتايوان تواجه مشكلة عويصة
ومجنون كوريا يسرق النوم من اعين
جيرانه. التملق الفرنسي يتواصل
للجزائر وتركيا من سياسة الحرب
الى سياسة القضاء. الكيان
الاسرائيلي يعترف بالحقيقة
والرئيس المصري يخطط لمستقبل
بلاده بمساعدة الولاية المتحدة
الامريكية فهل ينجح روسيا تضغط
بشدة لكل حرب قائد ولكل سياسة
شيطان. هنا يظهر شيطان السياسة
الامريكية الثعلب هنري كاسنجر
محذرا ان امريكا واوروبا امام
مفترق الطرق وان الوقت يقترب من
اجل احلال سلام قائم على التفاوض
في اوكرانيا للحد من مخاطر نشوب
حرب عالمية مدمرة اخرى. لكن حذر
من ان رغبة البعض في تفكيك روسيا
قد تؤدي الى فوضى نووية وفق
تعبيره. بينما كان الكريملين قد
اكد ان روسيا قد بدأت دراسة
الفكرة التي طرحها العجوز الخبير
كاسنجر معتبرا انه طرح افكارا
مثيرة للاهتمام حول اوكرانيا
واوروبا. لتخرج المندوبة
الامريكية لدى الامم المتحدة
ليندا توماس قائلة ان على روسيا
ايقاف هجومها الوحشي على بينما
دعا الرئيس الاوكراني دول العالم
الى الانخراط فيما وصفها بصيغة
سلام عالمي. وقال زين النسكي يجب
ان يصبح السلام هو البطل كما هو
الحال في مونديال قطر. ومن
الامنيات والدعوات الاوكرانية
السيطرة على مدينة باخموت
الاستراتيجية في مقاطعة دونسك
دون تحقيق اي اختراق ميداني على
الارض بسبب التصدي الاوكراني
للهجمات الروسية المتتالية. وبين
تمسك اوكراني واستماتة روسية
تحولت باخموت الى مدينة اشباح.
ليعلنها زعيم الانفصاليين في
دونيسك قوات فاغنر تقترب من
احكام الحصار على باخموت. لكن
زالانسكي اكد ان قوات بلاده لا
تزال تحكم السيطرة على المدينة
رغم الاعداء تحويلها الى انقاض
حسب تعبيره. مضيفا ان على
الشركاء ان يساعدوهم في تأمين
اجوائهم بتزويدهم بانظمة دفاع
جوي. وفي ظل استعدادات روسية
لهجوم واسع النطاق في اوكرانيا
بحسب ما يقال وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويجو يتفقدوا مواقع قواته
المنتشرة في منطقة العملية
العسكرية الخاصة باوكرانيا بينما
تتجه بوصلة الحرب الى النجارة
بلاروسيا التي اعلن سكرتير امنها
القومي ان القيادة العسكرية في
بلاده تحافظ على حالة تأهب الجيش
في ظل التهديدات التي تتعرض لها
البلاد على حد قوله. وهناك سفن
حربية وغواصات نووية وحاملات
طائرات في البحر الابيض المتوسط
وبحر البلطيق موجهة نحو روسيا
وبلاروسيا وفقا لوكالة تاس
الروسية. جاء ذلك بينما تشرع
قوات روسية في تدريبات تكتيكية
في بلاروسيا التي يزورها بوتين.
فما الذي يدبر له الرئيس الروسي?
احفاد الملكة اليزابيث يترجلون
عن خيلهم الذي اوشك ان في مضمار
السباق. نعم نقصد رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك الذي اثار
مخاوف الاوكران ان لندن ستسحب
مساعداتها العسكرية لكييف بحسب
صحيفة ديلي اكسبرس وذلك في الوقت
الذي تدخل فيه الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية مرحلة حرجة. فهل يترك
الانجليز اوكرانيا في وضع حرج
وينقضون عهودهم لينقذوا اقتصادهم
المتدهور? الانجليز انفسهم
يأبهون بما يجري في اوكرانيا
ويستعدون لحرب قادمة. وذلك
بتخزينهم الكثير من الامدادات في
منازلهم في صورة هي اشبه باولئك
الذين يوشكون على دخول الحرب.
والامر العجيب ان التخزين في
منازل البريطانيين لا يقتصر على
الغذاء بل وصل حتى لتخزين
السلاح. والمصدر شبكة سكاي نيوز
البريطانية. صدمة اخرى موجهة
للناتو هذه المرة من المانيا
وذلك باعلان فشل سلاح كان الحلف
بانتظاره. اذ اكد الجيش الالماني
انه واجه مشاكل فنية خطيرة اثناء
التدريبات مع مركبات الجندي
المدرعة من طراز بوما التي ينخفض
الاستعداد التشغيلي لها الى
الصفر لتتوقف تماما وفقا لصحيفة
بيلد الالمانية. بوتين يعلنها.
نحن نريد نظاما عالميا جديدا
تتساوى فيه جميع الدول. واضاف ان
روسيا لا تعيش فقط حاليا مرحلة
تغييرات كبيرة ولكن العالم باسره
يتغير. فيما قالت المندوبة
الامريكية لدى الامم المتحدة
جرينفيلد ان قرار انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا بيد الرئيس بوتين مضيفة
ان جو بايدن مستعد للتحدث مع
نظيره الروسي بشأن خطة سلام في
اوكرانيا. لكن الروس يحذر
الامريكان على لسان سفيرهم في
واشنطن الذي قال ان ارسال
الولايات المتحدة منظومات صواريخ
باتريوت الدفاع الجوي الى
اوكرانيا قد يكون له عواقب لا
يمكن التنبؤ بها. ليخرج الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قديروف معلقا على
ادراج اسمي ابنتي عائشة وخديجة
على لائحة عقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبي قائلا استمرا في
طريقكما يا ابنتي الصغيرتين
الرقيقتين. فالغرب باسره يخاف
منكما كخوفه من الجحيم. واضاف
انه فخور جدا بهما واهلا بكما في
قائمة عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي
حسب تعبيره. خصوم الصين في
تزايد. العوائق لا تنتهي امام
اصحاب العيون الضيقة. واليابان
تضع نفسها في مواجهة التنين
الصيني. ها هي التحضيرات
الياباني بعد ارتفاع حدة
التوترات في شبه الجزيرة الكورية
والمنطقة المحيطة بها وبعد زيادة
خيالية لميزانية طوكيو العسكرية
لا يزال الجيش الصيني يحتل
المرتبة الثالثة عالميا بينما
يحتل الجيش الياباني المرتبة
الخامسة. وبكين تقول لستم الا
لقمة سائغة امامنا ايها
اليابانيون. ومن اليابان الى
تايوان والتي يتوقع تكون لقمة
اسهل بكثير من اليابانيين. حيث
كشفت تقارير امريكية ان الجيش
التايواني يواجه مشكلة في تجنيد
الشبان بما يلبي الحاجات
العسكرية فتايوان في ظرف سنوات
ستكون ذات ادنى معدل مواليد في
العالم بحسب شبكة سي ان ان.
جيران كيم يصرخون. جيران كوريا
الشمالية ياخذون استراحة قصيرة
من صواريخ كيم جونج لكنه يعود
دائما ليذكرهم مرة اخرى. هو
بشحمه ولحمه يستعرض قدرات بلاده
الصاروخية باطلاق جديد بينما
اليابان تحتج بشدة لتنقل رويترز
خبرا بان كوريا الشمالية اطلقت
صاروخين باليستيين متوسطي المدى
باتجاه الساحل الشرقي لشبه
الجزيرة الكورية وقد قطعا مسافة
نحو خمسمائة كيلومتر. ياتي هذا
الاطلاق بعد ايام فقط من
الاختبار الذي اجرته بيونج يانج
على محرك يعمل الوقود الصلب بقوة
دفع كبيرة يقول الخبراء انه
سيسمح باطلاق اسرع الصواريخ
الباليستية لترد كوريا الجنوبية
ان سلوك كوريا الشمالية بابتكار
الصواريخ سيعرض النظام الكوري
للخطر مضيفة انهم سيدفعون الثمن.
هدوء تركي. تريث تركي قبل
العاصفة. لكن هل يفعلها الاتراك
ويطلقون حربهم سوريا. وبرغم ان
موسكو اكدت تفهمها مخاوف انقرة
ودوافعها للتخطيط لعملية عسكرية
برية شمال سوريا. فانها اكدت
انها تواصل مساعيها للحيلولة دون
تنفيذ هذه العملية. وترى موسكو
ان هذه العملية البرية ستؤدي
لمزيد من عدم الاستقرار في
المنطقة. فما الذي يفكر به
اردوغان يا ترى? يفكر الرئيس
التركي بتأمين الداخل في بلاده
قبل حيث تقضي محكمة تركية بسجن
رئيس بلدية اسطنبول ومنعه من
ممارسة السياسة ليعلن اردوغان ان
المحاكم ستصحح اي اخطاء في عملية
الاستئناف. الاحداث والتطورات.
تزامنا مع زيارة وزير الداخلية
الفرنسي للجزائر ماكرون يتصل
بنظيره عبدالمجيد تبون لبحث
العلاقات الثنائية والتعاون بين
البلدين. معركة تطالب
الاسرائيليين بمغادرة الاراضي
المحتلة من قبل الكيان الى
الولايات المتحدة خوفا من
المستقبل والمتطرفين بحسب صحيفة
معاريف الاسرائيلية بل تغادر فلا
مكان لكم ايها المحتلون. نشاط
مكثف للرئيس المصري عبدالفتاح
السيسي في واشنطن ولقاءات مع
كبار المسئولين الامريكيين على
هامش القمة الامريكية الافريقية.
اسلحة روسية تضر ومناطق اوكرانية
تختفي ودول اوروبية تتراجع.
برأيكم ما الذي تخبئه الاقدار
لاوكران